[Applause]
they are four times more likely to be
involved in the youth justice system
five times more likely to be excluded
from school
40 times more likely to end up homeless
looked after children are amongst the
most disadvantaged people in the united
kingdom
they are also more likely to have mental
health challenges as about half of them
have been diagnosed with some form of
mental illness
and they are more likely than their
peers to have special education needs as
11 as 59 of them are seen to have
special education needs by the time that
they're 11 years old
that's a lot
but the authorities in this space are
not passive
they are actively looking for ways to
improve the experiences of children in
care
and by children in care in the uk we are
talking about all children that are
looked after by the government for a
period of more than 24 hours so
most common is foster children
looked after in a home with maybe
parents that owned the home and then we
could have residential care for
more organized homes with multiple
children more adults that are trained to
take care of children and then you could
have supported
supported placements are for older
children between 16 and 18 in the uk
looked after children are between 0 to
18 years old so 16 and 18 you're going
towards independence and you're just
being guided towards that independence
and that's
it's an order like that
foster is normal
more or less and then
residential is when it's an escalation
if you're moved from foster to
residential and then support it is just
a normal progression because you're
growing older and when you're 18 years
old you would leave care
however if these children do not have a
good experience in care they end up to
have really poor outcomes in life um so
the authorities are actively looking for
how to improve the experiences of
children while in care and to increase
their chances of succeeding when they
leave the care system however they lack
access to timely insights on what is
working the effectiveness of
interventions
and updated areas of need as a matter of
fact sometimes insight comes six to
eight in six to eight months late and
this is not a typical case where you say
there is no data no instead there is a
lot of data collected we are good in the
uk at collecting data there's a lot of
data collected about children and care
however there is little insight
this is because the data is dirty
summarily it's not trustworthy so you
could get the analysis of oh this these
are the main movements of children or
this is how many children are entering
or living here but somebody really you
cannot trust it eight months out of 12.
and that is because
um the the dfe portal that is used to
check the integrity of the data is
available just once a year dfe is
department for education and they are
the part of the central government that
these local authorities have to give the
data to every year
so for some context um in the uk we have
various local authorities that collect
data about the children in their care
and then once a year we call this
statutory return so the government says
these are the kinds of data you should
collect these are kind of variables we
want to look at and then every local
authority collects that exact same kind
of data and then uploads it and gives it
to the central government for summary
reports every year
however when i talk about um
dirt in the data i'm talking about
we have the usual nand styles in
everybody's data
but i'm talking about things like the
dates of adoption of a child cannot be
before the date of birth of the child
like you have to be born in order to be
adopted of course
but then we have
less obvious things like a child that is
less than 16 years old cannot be in
supported placements so if you look at a
child's data
data from their check-in and you realize
that they have been
labeled as being under supported
placement and they are less than 16
years would then that's something to
flat so you have logical things like
that and more obvious things um however
this there are a lot of rules actually
and these rules are determined by the
dfe 287
last time i checked so sometimes they
add more rules um to things that should
not happen in your data um 287 rules
about 80 000 children in care in the uk
it's not practical for human eyes to go
through all that data and spots those
errors so we have to look for some form
of automation um that is why they have
to wait for the dfe portal which is
available only once a year that means
that
eight months out of 12 they just have a
lot of data that well they cannot use
and then when the dfe portal gets um
available we have this three-month
period where everyone is rushing to
correct their data so it's it's it's a
layered structure this way social
workers work directly with the children
who are in care
and then you have social analysts
analyze the data collected by social
workers then you have commissioners the
leadership the authorities that actually
make the decisions that change things or
have to
relate with the local i mean with the
central government okay
so what happens is that this social this
social care analyst the ones who just
work with the data when this three-month
window comes and then the dfa portal is
available what happens is that okay if
they spot let's let's go back to our
example of a child is um six years old
and marked as supported placement okay
that's an error um what they have to do
is they have to call or contact the
social worker who took that value and
then get them to correct it to actually
find out what the correct value is
that's a very time consuming process to
do anyway but having to do that maybe
eight months after the value was
recorded when some of these social
workers the people who collected the
data might have moved on to other jobs
because this sector has high attrition
rates so people move on often
so sometimes the person that collected
the data is not even present and then
it's so much work that when this window
comes this collection window comes it's
the main thing that analysts do nothing
else so we have analysts that are doing
less of analysis and more of data
cleaning
just so much so little insight um in the
sector
so we had this study with them we i work
at social finance i will talk about it
later
but we partnered with a few local
authorities to see whether these pain
points are common across the country and
when we found that okay the main thing
was
data could not be trusted so there were
two things we could do we could say
preventing um
preventing human error at the start of
the data or filling the data into the
systems into the various case management
systems or helping them to check the
errors and this was a faster way or more
logical more logical first step in um
getting
impact i would say um so we decided to
create an error checker that is
available throughout the year to help
them to see
um the errors in their data day by day
so that you could actually just check
the data values that came in yesterday
and flag that this is probably wrong
okay but
this came with an interesting set of
problems too um because of course we
were like errol check out cool that's
what we are creating that will probably
solve the problem everybody is happy
um but then
we will realize that we are we exist in
an interesting sector
where
to scale a tool across the uk is
an interesting thing to do
and that is because in order for you to
process data in a tool you need the data
and the tool to be in the same place
obviously
but then
to make that happen
two things are involved they could
either give their data to us or
we could put it on the internet and then
they upload it on the internet but then
this is extremely sensitive data so um
we have gdpr in the u that was not
possible like you have data about the
names and the locations of these
children live and it was live like there
was nothing you could tell anybody to
get that data on the internet for any
reason um so that was not an option um
because of governance issues then the
next thing was oh what if we could
install the tools in their computers the
local analyst computers i mean the
social workers who work in the local
authorities what what if we could
install um they told me their computers
so that they are able to use it even
without the internet
um
and then that came
that brought up another interesting
blocker because the uk is very
decentralized so we have the central
government and then we have the local
authorities which are about 151 local
authorities and each local authority has
its iit departments and there's no i.t
department that approves anything for
the rest um so we would have to go
through each iet department and get them
to give approval for the installation of
the two and they are giving approval for
the tool as is and then whenever we make
a big update or a change in futures we
would have to do that again 151 trips
across the country
that was not a viable solution we wanted
to spend more time in building and
iterating and creating something that
will improve the experiences of people
that are trained
to find insight on how to improve the
experiences of these children in care
so
this is a summary of the problems that
we have
now something else
something not a constraint i would say
but something else was required the tool
had to be in python
and that is because
the the main goal was analysis and
python has this full scientific stack
that makes it really um
[Music]
really adapted for analysis it's like my
preferred language for analysis and
tends to be many people's preferred
languages for analysis too
and then another thing is python was
beginning to gain popularity uh among
local authorities so it kind of its
reputation wins ahead of it so if we
wanted to build something look at the
audiences mostly use excel now
so you know how people are
not so embracing to change sometimes um
so python was something that they were
already embracing so that we wanted to
step on that um so it had to be in
python
but we wanted to have the user interface
we wanted to have a good user interface
we didn't want to sacrifice the user
experience so we had to we wanted to
build the front end in javascript too so
right now we cannot we cannot get users
to install our tool we cannot upload it
and we cannot get them to upload their
data on the internet it has the backend
has to be in python front-end has to be
in javascript we needed a way to compile
python in the browser without losing any
of its data science capabilities wow
allowing the use by allowing the user to
run the program in their computer
without uploading their data to the
internet
payout perfect
um
so we came across
piodite compiles python in the browser
so it basically um it compiles python
it's webassembly which is like bitcode
for compiled code and then that's like
portable enough to be sharable on the
web and then when the web browser loads
it it com
it compiles it into native code um
essentially
pyrodive runs on the io diet model it
was launched in one of these pi data
meetups and the iodide model allows the
ui to be connected directly to the
kernel without the need to pass through
the server
so we are able to run
the whole the user is able to run
the whole setup of the tool
without the need of the internet so the
way it works is that the user connects
to the ins to a link on the internet the
pi scripts get loaded into their local
environment then they can go offline and
run the validation of the tool we don't
structure that data
and we have achieved um an error checker
tool scaled across the uk
so
that's it
first problem solved now the second is i
work at a not-for-profit who has a
um how would i say we have
one of our favorite things to do is to
make ourselves redundant um so when we
work on something the idea is that we
train someone to do it so that we don't
have to do it anymore so and then we
have to look for something else to do
and the question when we started
building this is what happens to it in
five years in ten years
who maintains it who fixes bugs who
updates the futures when the dfe
releases new rules um that define the
integrity of the data
who adds those rules to the tool
and that's a question that we pointed
about for a while and we decided on in
whose best interest is the life of this
tool and it was those same students
social care analysts so we brought them
along with us
through this journey we trained them how
to train them in python code like from
scratch how to code in python
builds like the larger infrastructure of
the project um testing joining
joining the backend and the front end um
and then
we
not um we collaborated them as they
built the tool around along with us so
the 287 rules were coded one by one um
with the help of these children social
care analysts so teaching we were
teaching and giving them a chance to
practice in real life
but this came with added benefits too um
the fact the fact that they learned how
to code
not just means that we had someone to
maintain it when we're gone it also
meant that we had domain knowledge it
means when we look at a rule and it
doesn't seem obvious to us what that
rule means we had someone to ask these
people so we have somehow um had the
opportunity to have a tool that was
has the possibility i would say of
becoming more accurate because you have
the people who work with the data day by
day know exactly how it's going to look
like
and then another thing is
they know how to code and that just has
its own advantages because the whole
idea is that they spend so much time
cleaning data instead of getting inside
um but then there's there are a lot of
things that they spend so much time
doing that might not be obvious to us
but if they don't how to code they will
probably start automating those little
tasks that they do so it has like this
overflow effect
which we're looking forward to see and
we have started seeing already
so so far
this has been the impact of the tool
we are committed to working on things
that have an impact that we can see
linearly not not doing something that we
think
will do another thing that will create
impacts yeah
we like to see um
what exactly are we doing now
that will improve the lives of people
and so far we have done an estimate to
say that these two will save 130 days
per year
per local authority for an average local
authority so they will suddenly have all
this free time
people that are best trained to work
with children in care people that have
the passion for this suddenly have 130
days to do whatever they want to do with
it and we are looking forward to see
what they do
because the truth is what if
those who
have the knowledge suddenly have the
time and that's what this project is
enabling
another thing is it's been scaling
organically um and we have 70 out of the
151 local authorities using the tool
already so people are
practically just like telling their
friends about it so it's it's receiving
a lot of um love and appreciation and we
are really happy to have created
something um that is useful for the
community
and we have this analyst community now
that can write python code can identify
malfunction and can fix books um
recently we've had them actually
identify books and then we'll say that
okay we'll get back to that later on and
come back to the brief point it's been
fixed already and wow that was it
brought so much rejoicing
when that happened and it kept happening
and it's like it's it's a thing that we
look forward to at work just seeing
those changes on the ripple
so now i'll do a demo a demo of the tool
um
let's
can you still see my screen okay
so this is how it looks like
this is how it looks like
um this framework is the gov.uk
framework it is mostly used when
designing tools that have to be used by
the public and so that's how it looks
like um so they come and click start
i'll do like a very simple demo click to
upload files
these are this is fake data because we
don't have i don't have clearance to
that data right now um gdpr says that
you would have data only while you're
using it
and if you are not using it then you
have to give it away so we couldn't just
keep that around
so this is it
and then we click validate so you could
actually just
choose the particular rules you want to
check
or you could
you could um
validate all of them
this requires some patience but let's
click validate
ah
that's going give it like a minute so
don't hold your breath like when that
biodiet we are still um working on how
to optimize the the speed of this
experience um but that's loading oh i
wanted to do a demo of it offline maybe
i should do that again but i'll do it
the second time with fewer rules but
that's how it works but while that load
i would also want to just mention
something small like you can see oh you
can't see uh there's a button below that
says download 903 csv so we have this
monthly meetings okay it has run
let me talk about this before i go back
to the csv um an example is so it flags
the things that do not look okay so you
see it has flat two as sex and it has
flat mother the mother field and that's
just for the ad1 file um if i go to the
episode file then it flags more things
missing files so like that um
oh at the top that's the header file
yeah
so an example of the errors so it flags
the errors in red the particular
locations generating the error and then
you would see the error codes um like
165 data entry for moda is invalid um
you see moda is missing and it has to be
filled
it has to be filled with a value even if
that value says that the mother is not
known this is a code for that um
so and then charge is looked after but
modafield is not completed so this same
this same
data entry has flagged to
um to rows to error codes
so that's what the analysts do so we
have basically replicated um the error
checker tool um but in a way that they
have access to it every single day every
hour or minutes um
and i wanted to talk about this
csv converter let me just open it again
so it's 903 dot data to inside okay
data inside.org start
a csv so that's it loading the python so
when it loads the python then i can go
offline
okay and then we could load that again
while i'm talking about something else
um so just to talk about this
that has appeared here come on
why does that okay it's more visible
here 903 csu converter that just came up
from a very interesting conversation we
were having um with the analysts where
they said that some people have their
data in csv form and some people have
their data in xml form but most people
want to have their data in csv form and
the way their question was could we have
something that converts xml to csv now
for us that seems like an obvious thing
that should exist already and it
probably exists on the internet but then
coming back to the constraints of this
particular space where they have these
extremely sensitive data so the fact
that something exists on the internet
doesn't mean that they have access to it
um so that was just a little addition
that we added to the tool to enable them
to put in the xmls and get our csv yeah
that's
something more basic then i'll leave
this so this is offline now um and then
i'll just load it i'll load the
the files again to run as i continue the
presentation and then we'll come back
and check on it um so you could load
that csvs maybe let's try with xml this
time
oh come on i deleted my xml files um csv
then
yeah there you go then
validates
okay so while that goes on
let us continue
demo has been done
now
at the end of the projects we were
reflecting on
just reflections we tend to do that a
lot at the ends of projects and we're
like we now have a community of domain
experts that can code and we have the
ability to process data at scale we have
constant data structures
what more could we do with this it
seemed like we could do more with it and
we are thinking of could we possibly
have the recipe for an analysis platform
and i would just go ahead to talk about
what that could look like
um so far we we have done the
903 is the name of the quality
of the looked after children data set
it's called ssda903
so we have done the ingest and
validation of that data and we have done
an error checker for it um but then it's
a really big space because there are
like five states history data returns
that have to be done for children in
children in cairo looked after children
and then over
across all areas there are about a
hundred statutory data returns that have
to be done pay local authority um to the
central government per year um so what
could we do
with
the infrastructure that we've created
what if we could do the same what if we
could create an error checker for
children in need data for school data
special needs data
and then what we could link all that
data together what is what is it going
to enable us to have
could we have
could we possibly be able to do
more types of analysis like we could do
exclusions analysis now understanding
what causes children to be pushed out of
school we could um do
understanding of missed risk so children
in need is like extremely vulnerable
children are there some signs that we
should have seen that we didn't see that
cost us not to be able to give this
child help when they needed it
we could look at that and we could look
at ways of preventing that um or just
statutory return analysis in general um
and the interesting thing about this is
that exclusions analysis has been done
already
we did that as a project so we actually
took the the real data and combined it
and we did the cleaning and combines it
but it's not scalable but it's just
something that we have but we're not
able to share that we just shared the
powerpoints and we created a report that
was published and people just saw like
the static
the static uh nature of it like this is
how it looks like now um but now that we
have pyrodiet we could create this into
a live format this same the same
cleaning and joining we could create it
into the live format that year by year
people as people are able to see um
analysis of exclusions and say okay we
said that we'll focus on doing this to
prevent children from leaving school is
it working now are they still living for
the same reasons um and then race equity
analysis maybe if we want to
analyze special needs education or
children that have special education
needs sen um
and this is where we are now
now we've created the 903 return we have
the ingest to validate that is actually
a 903 file
because the way it works is that if even
if you upload a file that is not really
903 but it has the columns of 903 a2 is
able to pick the columns that it wants
out of it name the name the file
correctly and then continue the process
so we have a quite robust ingest process
then we have an error checker which i
showed you um and then
yeah the visualization in the front end
um and then this is what we're looking
to build actually we have already
started plans for um since is children
in need so that's extremely vulnerable
children
so
this is where we are now we are starting
sin uh in august
but right now what i am working on
is
a demand modeling tool forecasting tool
to help local authorities budget for the
future because there's an influx of
children into care but local authorities
are not able to plan appropriately
because they don't know how how many
children are coming into care how much
it's going to cost relative to inflation
and all the other variables that affect
the ability of us to support the
children that most in need in our
society
and the project i'm working on now is a
demand model into a forecasting tool
that takes into consideration all the
movements of children within care and
into care and out of care
and it's something that
we already did in excel
as an excel tool and
of course was not able to scale before
because we couldn't get
to scale we need the internet in some
form and we couldn't get um
users to upload their data to the
internet and pio data has just enabled
that so pyrodive is is bringing is
allowing us to
scale so many tools that we've already
created and we're just sitting in the
cupboard somewhere and it's opening up
far new spaces bringing more
opportunities more partners into this
space and another tool that we are
working on is i i will talk about our
tools i'll talk about our
areas of work in general at social
finance it's a not-for-profit um that
works on high-impact areas we work
across a range of areas adult social
care hope um
housing and homelessness i mean housing
and homelessness adults social care
improving the experiences of children in
social care
health and employment helping people
with mental challenges fit into work and
stay there because we believe that
the only way for people to learn how to
work is to work um but another another
tool that we created is um the family
context tool which has to do now with
the social workers so you remember if
you have the child we have the social
worker that actually meets the child and
then we have the social care analysts
that analyze the data about the child so
social care analysis what this the tool
i just talked about that's what it was
created to help to make the the
systems more efficient and then now the
family contact students for social
workers those who actually go to these
children's houses and hold the
children's hands um and make the
decisions about where the children are
going to stay
and
so far they would spend about three
hours finding information about the
child okay you have this far uncooler
and somewhere
um
main thing is adhesive for you to go and
stay with them that's the question that
we want to answer and family context is
a project that links multiple data sets
um we are obviously saving three hours
per case so that that we are suspended
with a child instead of um
searching for data we are bringing all
that data into one space
such that by a simple search of a
child's name you're able to get
information about
the child circumstances we have linked
adult social care data and housing data
and um
it's customizable so every local
authority decides what kind of data they
should be linked
but when we started with stockpot
council those were the two
um main ones that were present and then
exclusions analysis we do deep dive
analysis sometimes so sometimes we build
tools and sometimes we just get curious
about an area and do a deep dive into
the area to find out well are we making
any assumptions here or is there
something that we've been ignoring so
far and we
kind of did a deep dive into exclusions
from school so exclusions i'm talking
about when the authorities ask a child
not to come to school anymore as a way
of punishing the child um so what
happens is they would do temporary
exclusions so leave school for two or
three days and come back and then
sometimes you do permanent exclusions we
never want to see you again
so we are trying to prevent that because
children are excluded from school
have very bad outcomes in life if you
have been excluded from school at some
point in your life so when we made that
connection we decided to dig into how to
prevent that from happening and we were
a little bit surprised because so far
the assumption is that boys get excluded
more from school
and then we found that girls get
excluded equally in some
um under some variables for example boys
get excluded formally from school like
go but like
go design the document or something but
girls get excluded as well managed
transfers from one school to another or
um
long long periods of absence or just
it's never formal for girls but when we
found that it kind of brought some it
brought some attention to the space that
maybe we shouldn't direct all
all the interventions towards this
particular set there might be another
set of people that might need help
equally
um
that's me and we have more links here in
the slides
um the full discovery report when we
entered the space and we had no idea uh
how to improve children social care
until when we decided that an error
checker might be the first good thing to
do that's in the discovery report it's
like it's really nice to be true and all
our code is is open source it's online
um you could see it there and then
social finance projects in general
that's the repo for that and children
services projects is another um related
ripple um to read about this project you
could look at that blog and to read
about pioud and the scientific stack in
the browser you could look at that blog
thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much that was excellent
we've got a bit of time for q a now
okay
thank you very much for the presentation
was super inspiring
so
i have like a couple of questions one i
don't know if you've looked into pi
script which
apparently builds on top of biodiet so
maybe could save some work but i'm not
exactly sure and on the other hand i
don't know if you could comment a little
bit more on how you're teaching social
workers to code because i find that
super intriguing and like to what extent
they're able to do data analysis or what
tools they use or anything like that
okay okay um so we got
we got the volunteers by just saying
well we want to build this tool and we
want to teach people a new language who
is interested and we got like a whole
lot of people interested and then
initially
for them to learn how to we taught them
basic python the basic the base of
python and then we taught them the
things that they needed to build the
project so it was recorded videos at the
start where you go through these python
modules to get an idea of what
programming is and what the language is
and then
we had these videos to teach them how to
create um an error function it was it
was pi tests basically every rule was
created as some sort of partis um by
test function so
got them to learn how to do that and as
they progressed through the project then
they started getting interested and
seeing maybe the ingress.pi file how
does it work so it was a very gradual
process like and people that get more
interested get to dip their feet into
the water a little more um poor and
everything was done on github so you
would actually see the pull request
there yeah that's how it's working it's
an ongoing process because we are
we are taking them along to this same
project starting very soon and we want
to onboard a new set of a new set of
analysts the plan is to totally be able
to detach ourselves from it in three
years or so
ok
sorry
that was a great presentation um my
question is a bit generic uh so with
this tool that you've built what are
your challenges that you're facing
currently especially because you want to
go ahead with your analysis for children
in need so what are the challenges that
you're facing to make this more um
make
put in more data science to it you know
to uh extend your use cases
okay okay um
especially of course you see the speed
of the speed of loading we could make
that better hopefully
um
but the idea is that we are aren't the
ones who do the analysis the whole idea
of the community is that the analysts
who normally do analysis on excel
move that knowledge to
python and then
collaborate on it
using the tool so
we do analysis and publish reports but
we want to make that more
scale where the people actually working
with this data day-to-day get to do the
analysis and share
problems that we are facing so far
with doing analysis
nothing comes to mind exactly because
this was a main blocker for a whole lot
of time
and that is that is resolved already i
don't know it i find it hard to remember
problems if i didn't um write them down
yeah
i think he's had us okay
we could
just
thank you so much for the presentation
i was wondering if you had any
challenges around uh being able to
convince people that the data are not
actually leaving the computer and how
you manage some of that yeah
i guess
it's time for me to just show that that
has actually run successfully it was
very okay that has run successfully
offline
you could see i'm still offline it was
very useful for us to actually
demonstrate that if i go offline
when you're offline everybody knows that
you're cut from the internet the tool
still works because it's a fear these
people work with very sensitive data and
they are very careful about gdpr and
the fact that i can work offline was a
very big um
banner that helped them to onboard
themselves to this project yes
and we got it tested by like external
people
cool so we've got a couple of minutes
maybe time for one more question i think
his hand was up
okay no yes
yeah i was wondering how do you um if
you worry about like people
um
looking to the errors and trying to
solve all of them
even when they don't have the
information so for example in the case
of gender you can have like an ambiguous
situation that like
people put that number there or
something meant that
that was ambiguous but then
somebody else see the error and try to
fill
with
something that
needs to match there or if like the
local authorities start to pressuring
people to get rid of all the errors and
they start like to feeling information
that's inaccurate if you worry about
that happening um this is an error
checker so
they don't correct the data here
yeah so this just does
what the dfe error checking portal was
supposed to do but was available only
once a year so we started by solving the
base problem making that available
throughout the year but they have
processes in place at each local
authority to prevent people from
randomly changing inform
randomly changing important information
about children so those same processes
exist we haven't um boycotted those yeah
you had a question
we've got five minutes until the next
talk so yeah
yeah can we say a big thank you and
hopefully there will be some more
information if you want to share it on
the slack if you're not on that let me
know
everyone else if you're having any
trouble with the slack qr codes there is
another one circulating about so
yeah
thank you very much